hi I'm Alexandra Daddario and welcome to
my detail shoot my mother would kill me
if my mother would kill me if I got a
tattoo what would that tattoo be I'd
want to do something personal or
something you know maybe something on my
back like Angelina Jolie ish the best
advice a boss ever gave me was to be on
time I had trouble when I was young
being on time and I got in trouble a
couple times for it and now I have like
PTSD when I'm late so I always try to be
on time otherwise I have a panic attack
my best friend is my dog if I could have
anyone speak at my funeral living or
dead it would be I would I would like
Steve Martin to speak at my funeral but
Steve Martin doesn't know me or know who
I am so I would like to get to know him
first and then have him speak at my
funeral I feel like he'd do a good job
of making it humorous and touching at
the same time one piece of advice I get
my 16 year old self is um I would say if
if I could go back in time and tell my
16 year old self one piece of advice I
would tell her to not be as afraid and
you know be confident and
believe in myself and I think that
that's something that sort of comes with
age you know because wasted me out